Hello.
Hi.
Do you like my getup?
Hello.
Welcome.
Hi.
Hold on, let me drink some water.
Welcome, welcome, welcome, welcome.
I feel bad.
That... I feel... Maybe... I feel like a... Like... Like... Like... I was gone for a week and then... And then... I put this up.
Don't... Don't... Don't... Uh... How do I say?
Um... I try... I was like... Oh, I'll just say it like it's a... Like it's a yapping stream.
It's no big deal.
But... I accidentally...
I think... Made some of you guys worry.
I'm sorry.
Oh, I accidentally made some of you guys feel bad.
And then I felt like... I was like... Oh, gosh.
There's so many people...
Waiting.
I think... Maybe people... Are expecting something big.
But it's not really.
I think maybe I... Accidentally... I'm like... What's the Streisand effect?
Or whatever.
Or... My own... Dingy.
Rechat was funny because of it.
Clickbait!
Well, not really.
It's still... Something I want to talk about.
I don't know.
But... Also... You guys are so...
Some of you guys are so...
You guys are going to have more faith in...
In... In your Oshis.
I think.
I don't think your Oshis would put like...
Oh, you're a small yap.
If they were going to...
Announce their graduation.
That would be so mean.
Thank you guys though for all the...
Gifted memberships and the Super Charts.
Thank you.
I was... I was gone for a week.
Which is not even that long of a time.
But it felt like a long time.
For me.
It always feels like a long time for me.
But...
Small yap.
I'm leaving forever.
Good boy.
You guys can probably already tell though...
What I'm going to talk about.
You can probably already tell.
I feel...
Yeah.
I have no idea.
That's okay.
God's sickest ghost.
How is it that I'm dead?
And yet...
Kiwawa!
You preggle.
With you?
From last time?
I thought we were safe.
Hold on.
Where...
Where'd she go?
You and Doki had fun on your honeymoon?
Oh yeah.
Doki was gone too, huh?
You couldn't hear my voice is a little bit.
And so it's going to be a bit of a shorter stream today.
That's why it's a short yap.
And then I'll talk about stuff for the next couple of months.
I think...
Not that...
No, I think.
I know.
Um...
It didn't get better.
Actually, it got...
It got worse.
I didn't even do anything.
I...
I didn't even like...
Like I just...
It just...
I didn't even do anything.
It got worse.
And it's bad.
Because I have so many deadlines this week.
But...
Um...
Yeah.
So for those who...
I was just going to talk about it, I guess.
For those who...
Um...
Probably...
No.
The past couple of months, I've been having some really bad struggles with my...
Um...
With my throat.
And my throat doesn't hurt.
So...
It's not anything like that.
If you're over just like...
Oh my god.
She's in pain.
No, no.
It's nothing like that.
Um...
And...
Uh...
Which is kind of bad.
Because like...
My...
My job is talking.
And...
Yeah.
Less yelling at idols.
Even at idol lives.
I haven't even been doing calls.
Which is...
I haven't been doing anything like that.
It's...
It's true.
When I go to an idol live...
If there's calls, I like...
I like just mouth it.
But uh...
But...
Um...
Say it ain't so.
It's because I've been trying to...
Make sure my voice is okay.
And it started...
Last year.
It started last year when I...
Got COVID.
Thanks, Mataracon.
And then...
Um...
And then I got...
Punkitis...
Earlier this year.
Where I completely lost my voice.
And...
I think that was kind of like...
The nail in the coffin.
And I've...
And I was like...
Looking it up.
And people are like...
Yeah, you really should like...
Let your voice rest for like...
Three months.
Don't do anything.
And I was like...
So...
The nail in the coffin.
You and Henya have had bad luck.
I know.
With that...
Yeah, I've heard too.
Because I asked her if...
Um...
I asked her about something too.
And she wasn't able to...
Do it.
Because she's like...
I can't.
Because of COVID.
Um...
But, you know...
Everybody's been kind of like...
Well...
You know...
Hope you've been feeling better...
Since you took the week off.
And...
Honestly...
Oh my gosh.
Thank you guys...
For letting me...
Take those days off too.
Because...
It was...
So...
So needed.
Oh my gosh.
It was so, so...
So, so needed.
So, um...
I was able to at least...
Get the things...
Done that I needed to.
It was really, really, really, really good.
So thank you.
Oh my gosh.
It was good, good, good.
Um...
And, you know...
So I wish I had like...
Better news.
I wish I could be like...
Yep!
I'm cured forever.
But, uh...
Yeah, I just haven't really given my voice...
I think the chance to recover...
Since January.
And I'm also...
I'm also on a new...
Medicine I've told you guys about before.
And it, like...
Kind of...
Makes my throat really dry.
And that's also not helping.
So...
Mmm...
Um...
It's been...
Tough.
I...
Go drink water.
I drink so much water.
You guys don't understand...
How much water I have.
How many cough drops I'm drinking.
Or...
Sucking on.
How much...
Those...
Those like...
Herbal...
Things...
For your throat.
I...
I do it all.
Like...
All day.
If there's something that you're telling me to do...
I'm already doing it.
So...
You don't even need to say anything.
Um...
I'm already doing it.
Voodoo.
I'm not doing that.
Maybe I should be doing voodoo.
But, um...
Have you consulted a specialist?
I...
I tried to.
I don't think I'll be able to go until after Japan.
Because...
I tried to make an appointment.
And it referred me back to my...
General doctor.
And...
So I think I have to get like a...
Referral...
Um...
To do it.
So...
And I don't know then...
After then...
When I'd be able to get an appointment.
So...
Yeah...
Um...
I did try.
Uh...
But, uh...
So...
Uh...
Yeah...
I don't know.
I'm trying not to like get upset about it.
Right now.
I'm upset about it, obviously.
Uh...
Because right now...
I have so many things...
Piling up.
And I'm like getting offers for things.
And the one thing that I need to work isn't.
Uh...
Um...
I don't want to just complain.
Sorry.
Japan's doctor.
Guys, I have no time during my Japan trip.
I have zero time.
During my Japan trip.
I...
I am busy, busy, busy.
It's a super duper busy...
Trip for me.
So...
Not this time.
There's no way.
Uh...
But...
Yeah...
I don't know.
I've just been really like...
For the past couple months.
So...
Frustrated.
Obviously.
I've...
I've expressed that.
Probably...
Countless.
Less times.
But...
So...
Because of that.
Um...
I...
I'm not...
Taking a break.
Per se.
But...
Definitely...
For the next...
Couple of months.
I'd say about three months or so.
That's when people say that...
Uh...
That's when...
They say like...
That's a good amount of time.
Uh...
So...
I'll be doing...
Less streams...
For the next...
Three months or so.
And...
Uh...
Probably like...
Reducing to like...
Three...
Streams...
Times a week or so.
Um...
Many, many less.
And then...
Probably...
Also...
Uh...
Probably no schedules...
For the next three months.
Because...
It will kind of be like...
If my...
Voice is feeling okay that day.
Or not.
So...
Uh...
Sorry.
I know some people are just like...
They really like schedules.
But after...
After...
So...
I'd say...
It's not...
It's almost May.
So June, July, August.
End of August.
Into September.
We...
We can...
We will...
Resume the schedules.
So it's only...
Temporary.
And...
Uh...
Um...
But I will give a...
Heads up.
Like I'll make the waiting room.
I'll make the waiting room early.
And like announce on...
Twitter.
And stuff.
With...
Time in advance.
Unless it's like...
Me being like...
I'm gonna play Oblivion.
Unless I'm like...
I wanna play Oblivion today.
But...
Uh...
Yeah.
So I'm sorry...
That you'll probably be seeing...
Less of me a little bit.
Uh...
I'm only gonna do...
Three streams this week.
Well actually...
I'm doing a collab with...
Coyote.
From Kimono Friends.
Um...
She wanted to do...
If you didn't see...
Uh...
I will be...
Appearing in her graduation live.
So...
Um...
And it's 3D.
Mm-mm-mm-mm-mm-mm...
And...
So that's one of the dances I've been...
Practicing a lot.
But...
Even though it's mostly us...
Just being silly goofy.
But yeah.
So...
Um...
Mm-mm-mm-mm...
So yeah.
That will be it.
Next week?
One of the reasons I'm in Japan.
Thank you guys, thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Silent streams.
I don't know if it's even possible for me.
I guess I could try.
Maybe, like, just play Oblivion in no voice.
Why do I keep... Everything goes back to Oblivion.
I've been wanting to play it so much.
Text-to-speech?
Then I would have to type.
How do you game?
If you have to type.
How do you game and type?
What if it's like...
What's the word?
Typing of the dead.
Two keyboards.
Yeah, right?
Just type faster.
You'll get me crashing out, but in text-to-speech.
I would be so stupid.
The text-to-speech crash out.
Yeah, I could use my toes.
So true.
So, so true.
With lots of typos.
Oh my gosh.
It would...
There will be...
Hold on.
Let's save and just try.
Text-to-speech.
With realistic AI voices.
Oh, I'm gonna go with Atom.
Newton's first law of motion.
Oh, I'm just scared.
Also known as...
Shut up.
Does this count as commercial use?
Everybody, don't send me any donos.
Don't send me any money right now.
Drag and drop your phone.
Oh.
Hold on.
Let's see.
Hello, my name is Mint Phantom.
Wow, that was pretty good.
That was pretty good.
Wait, how does he laugh?
Let's see how he laughs.
Because he got that minky flair.
No, I typed it way more than that.
There we go.
Oh, yeah.
Let's do it.
Okay, that's here.
Wait, what?
Oh, here we go.
Hahaha.
Jinzu-faya-fibo, weepa-tiga-tiga-tada-tada-tiga.
Chape-ape-care-a-kina-chape-ape-care-a-kina.
Myo-hantusook, weepa.
Oi!
Waka-e-ri-na-sai-mase, gosho-jin-sawa, ojyo-sama.
Okura-nasai-maze.
Gashi-jin-sama, ojyo-sama.
Hahaha.
Okura-nasai-maze.
I didn't know text-to-speech could be cringe.
I don't know, guys.
It does sound like he's saying it with like a southern accent.
Hahaha.
Wait, let's hear him say hot dog.
Hot dog.
Hot dog!
Hahaha.
Okay.
Mmm.
This should be good hee-hee.
Hehe.
I'll use Adam.
If I ever want a text-to-speech.
Hehe.
This is good hee-hee.
Watke hee-hee-hee-hee-hee-hee-hee-hee-hee.
Adam Phantom.
Do you think this is how Miller would speak Japanese?
Wait, hold on.
Can you hear that?
Can you hear me typing?
Okay.
You can?
Hello, my name is Kazuhiro Miller.
I am half Japanese and love Japan.
Konnichiwa!
Okay, I'm done.
I'm done with that.
That was so good.
My first day of learning Japanese.
Konnichiwa!
Oh, Nihongo Jozu.
Who sounded like...
I'm gonna end up laughing and stressing her words more.
Why don't we just text the speech stream?
I know, they're gonna make me laugh.
At least it's not the narrator.
Do you guys know that?
The narrator?
Do you guys know?
Sorry I'm late.
Thank you!
Thank you so much for the...
For the...
Thank you.
No?
Okay.
There's gonna be some people that are like, Don't...
Don't bring it back!
Don't do it!
Oh wait, that's not it.
Oh wait, I don't...
No.
Sorry.
I actually opened up the wrong thing.
Okay.
There's a special program called Voice Mod.
But I didn't download...
Let me download it right now.
Voice Mod.
I think this one.
Enter my code.
Know it all too well?
The narrator.
You guys who don't know the narrator will soon...
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
I'm so excited to introduce you guys.
I'm too excited for this.
I think.
Sorry.
I'm installing it right now.
I'm installing the program.
I'm way too excited to introduce some of you guys to the narrator.
I'm so excited.
I'm so excited right now.
Installing voice mod.
My gut muscles can't take it.
You guys will have abs.
At the end of this.
I promise.
You guys will have abs from how funny this is.
This is wholesome.
Is it?
Is this wholesome?
Okay, launch.
I know, I can't wait to see people's reactions.
Building a summer bod.
Yeah, I'm helping you.
I'm helping you.
Okay, get started.
Open.
Verifying account.
Is it verified?
Yeah.
Okay, open.
Sounds good.
My mic is this.
And my output is this.
But I don't want you guys to hear...
How can we do this?
I don't want you guys to...
Hear... Okay, I think I have an idea.
What to do.
Start using.
Okay.
Whoa.
The program has changed so much since I last used it.
Okay.
I'm gonna mute here.
Oh, you're also gonna lose the audio... Or the... The music.
I can... I can just have it play.
Oh!
Oh my gosh.
I've been talking this whole time.
Wait.
Sorry.
I was saying that I can add the music here.
But it might be loud at first.
I don't want to hurt your ears.
Um... I'm trying to figure out.
Sorry.
Okay.
Let me just... Let me just... Let me... Let me... Let me... Let me... Let me just do this.
New.
Test.
Can you hear me?
Can you hear me right now?
Oh.
Can you hear me?
It's loud.
Oh, sorry.
Okay.
Oh.
Ah...
Well, I had to turn it down like crazy.
Up, up, up, up, up, up, up, up.
That should be good.
Maybe.
No?
It's okay.
I don't even know what I sound like.
Hold on.
I need like a... Oh.
Hear myself.
Oh.
Blah, blah, blah, blah.
Okay.
Now...
I find...
The narrator.
What is this?
Oh, wait.
Pro.
Do I have...
Oh.
I have Pro.
I bought it.
Wait.
Go Pro.
I have Pro.
I bought it.
Wait.
It's saying that I don't have it.
No.
I... I did.
I bought it.
I... I... I have it.
I have this.
I bought like a...
A lifetime subscription thing.
I'm pretty sure.
But now it's saying I don't have it.
No way.
Don't do this to me.
I can't use the narrator.
Wait.
Scam.
I don't think it was an old account.
This is my only account.
It logged me in.
Um...
What's this button do?
Oh, it's a recorder.
No way!
Okay, hold on.
Um...
Transaction history.
Yeah, let me go to like the website and see my account.
It's not even like letting me see anything.
What is going on?
It like changed so many things.
What?
Wait, let me try a different account.
Let's see.
Maybe I did use a different email.
I'm just stupid.
Enter a code on install.
It didn't give me an option to do that.
It just installed it.
It did not give me an option to do any...
Add any code.
Let's see.
If I log out...
What do I log out?
Sorry.
This is becoming a thing, isn't it?
This is becoming a whole thing just for me to try this.
Eh...
Oh, log out.
Log out.
Oh, here we go.
It was a different email!
It was!
It says subscription status active.
One time payment offer.
Okay, now I need to figure out how to log out here though.
Uh...
Log out of my profile in...
Maybe it'll work now.
I'm so confused.
We are so back.
Oh yeah, baby.
Well, kind of.
We're almost there.
We're almost...
How do I...
I don't know how to...
Wait.
Actually, let me just close the program.
Okay, you can hear me again.
But it didn't log me out.
Hmm...
Oh!
Wait, account.
I found it.
Log...
We did it!
Okay.
Wait.
This one's called Ghost.
Hello.
It's so freaky.
Oh my god.
I'm like...
Five times.
Oh...
Five octaves higher.
Wait.
This one's called Gold disgust.
This one's called Villager.
Wow.
I couldn't even... Anything I said, I just sound like a Minecraft villager.
Okay, guys.
There's the date in the Minecraft movie.
Wait, this one's called Bowtie Billy.
It's like supposed to be the guy.
Wait, this one's called Genki.
What's Genki?
Lo-fi.
Whoa.
Wow.
I sound so... Say so.
Lady.
Konichiwa.
Um.
Uh.
Oh.
She sounds kind of...
Wow.
I keep having to... Just the... Voice.
William.
Okay, I'm gonna do the narrator now.
Wow.
Wait.
Did they?
They changed their... It sounds different.
Oh.
Oh, no.
Maybe not.
Wait.
The laugh is different, though.
Oh.
Oh
Wait...
You guys, there's one called Celestial Narrator.
There's one called Celest... What is this?
Okay, I'm gonna try it.
Hello.
Oh my god!
Why?
It's so having me well.
Why is it like this?
Yes.
Why should I kiss?
There's so many new narrators.
There's Presidential Narrator.
There's so... this is all so new now.
The new voice mod.
Oh my gosh.
I missed the old narrator.
You guys, it wasn't the same.
It wasn't the same.
Old narrator.
Wait, this one's called Creepy.
It has like a little creeper.
Wait, is it just gonna make me go...
Because they're so stupid.
Some of these though, I wanna try.
Like there's one called Kawaii.
Where is it?
Oh my gosh.
We're smart as...
So silly.
Wait, where'd it go?
I just saw it.
I'm gonna turn into...
I'm gonna turn into actual anime, you guys.
Oh my god.
What if I just use this and then I don't have to...
I don't have to...
Well, I would still have to speak, huh?
Okay, this one's Kawaii.
It's!
Su-goooy!
I'll take care!
It's a theory, huh?
I can change the colors.
Can you really understand...
Bitch.
I'm playing around the bitch.
It's crazy I'm saying...
It sounds like I'm saying...
It's just a chipmunk.
It's not normal.
It's not cute at all.
Okay, one more.
I'm gonna try one more.
Wait, this one is Lethal Employee.
They really just said, like, hey, this is Lethal Company.
Okay, this one is called Akari.
Wait.
I sound like a boba boy.
What's your name, Miku?
This is, like, I'm, like, the VTuber.
Damn.
What else should I say?
Um,
I'm thinking... wait, one.
That's awesome.
Dijian.
Oh, thank you.
I'm thinking Miku, Miku, oh, I'm thinking Miku, Miku.
If I... wait, one.
If I can hear myself, that's how I can only hear the voice, you know?
But then I can hear myself when there's a little delay.
And so it's weird.
I talk weird.
I talk...
oh, haha...
Okay I'm done... let me exit out of voice mine now.
I'm sad now.
I feel like the narrator.
I hyped it up.
I was like, oh my gosh, I'm so excited.
I hyped it up for nothing.
Dang.
Morgan Freeman still peaking.
They stabilized him too much.
Yeah, they fixed it.
It used to sound way more like scuffed.
And when he laughed, he would be like...
It was so good back then when he didn't sound as good.
Now he sounds too realistic.
Peace Walker Vocaloid Editor Revival.
Thank you, Lambda.
Thank you.
I don't know what games we're going to play.
I haven't really thought about it so much.
I'll be honest.
I've been way too busy to think about that.
AI Somnium Viles, maybe not bad though.
I got asked to do like a collab.
Like a Ace Attorney collab.
And I was like...
I can't...
I...
Which, if you don't know...
I played the trilogy.
And I voice acted all of it.
No, I voice acted all of it.
I played the trilogy...
Um...
Before I...
Before I went to heaven.
Oh, why not?
Because I can't read that much right now, you guys.
There's so much reading.
It's so much reading.
Yeah...
It's been...
It's...
It's really hard right now too.
Because I've been like...
I've been...
You know...
Obviously...
I'm still working on stuff.
And it's been a matter of...
Balancing how I can stream.
And also...
How I can...
Do some of these...
Projects.
You know what I mean?
So...
It's...
That's...
The...
Hardest thing.
At the moment.
Because like...
I'm getting opportunities for things.
But my voice is...
My voice can't do both.
Essentially.
My voice can't...
Sing and also...
And also stream...
For...
The amount of time...
That I want to.
So...
It's just...
That's where it's been.
And it's frustrating to me.
Because I feel like...
You know...
Obviously...
Things will...
Be shown to you guys eventually.
But...
Right now...
It's just...
It feels like...
I have nothing.
So I'm sorry.
Um...
Hopefully the lesser streaming load helps.
So...
Yeah...
I didn't want to say that I was taking like a break.
You know...
Until...
Until I can be like...
Yeah...
I think my...
And then of course I will also go to the...
Hospital...
And try and see a doctor and everything too...
So...
Reduce the schedule.
Yeah...
I just feel bad.
I'm sorry guys.
That I'm...
That...
That my ectoplasm is weak.
My ectoplasm is too weak.
You'd think I wouldn't have issues with this.
As a ghost.
But uh...
Yeah...
And I figured...
Um...
You know...
I feel...
I was like...
Maybe...
You know...
People would be...
Maybe a little more understanding...
Because of...
You know...
How we...
Lost someone...
Like...
Someone else graduated...
Not too long ago...
Due to...
Their throat...
And obviously...
I don't think it's...
At that point at all...
You know...
So...
Um...
Like...
I don't think it's even...
Close to that...
But...
I also would be so sad if I...
Couldn't...
Sing anymore either...
So...
Yeah...
So I...
Think...
I will call it...
Here...
Maybe...
I said...
I did say it would be a short...
Uh...
Yup...
So...
Um...
Thank you guys for letting me take the...
Week off...
And then of course I will be gone for...
Uh...
About a...
About almost maybe...
Two weeks...
Coming this...
End of this week...
Haha...
So...
Um...
Glad you have a chance to collab with Koyo...
Before she graduates...
Yeah...
Keep a good feeling balance...
Thank you...
Oh...
Don't stress over your voice...
Haha...
I cannot...
But...
Oh...
I stress so much...
I can't help but...
Only stress...
Haha...
Which I'm like...
It's kind of out of my control...
Like I didn't...
You know...
I didn't think I would get the bunkaitis...
And...
That it would...
You know...
I don't even...
Oh gosh...
Uh...
We'll do some stuff...
That like...
Doesn't involve me...
Singing...
Or talking too much...
Obviously I won't be doing any karaoke...
No karaoke streams...
For...
I don't know...
Well...
Maybe until my birthday...
Haha...
Um...
Yeah...
Movie watch-alongs...
And...
Um...
Things like that...
Eh...
Haha...
Nah...
Karaoke VOD replay...
Oh!
While I'm gone...
I will have a...
Probably...
Most likely a VOD...
Relay on...
I don't know if it'll just be karaoke though...
I don't have that many karaoke's...
Streams...
So...
Cough drops...
Tasting stream...
Oh...
Golly...
How...
I've...
God...
I have so many...
Actually...
Oh good...
Oh my goodness...
Yes...
I ran out of these ones...
These like...
Asahi...
Mintia voice ones...
Have been so good...
I have one package left...
So when I go back to Japan...
We'll get some more...
Tier list...
Haha...
These ones are so so good...
Because they're not like...
You know...
Like the menthol...
Like they feel...
Like...
But they help...
You can hear me opening...
Sorry...
It's lemon ginger...
So it tastes yummy...
And then it also...
Helps so much...
Come on...
Come out...
I lost my voice for like...
Four months...
A few years ago...
Turns out I just need music...
I'm scared though...
If I go to the doctors...
What if they have to shove something down my throat...
I'm scared...
Mintia...
But if they do...
If they take a picture...
I'll show...
I'll show you guys...
If they do...
I'll ask them to take a picture...
And then I'll show you guys...
Do you?
Okay...
You could call me...
Deep Throat...
Not the tonsil reveal...
What if they're like...
Really ugly...
Oh my gosh...
How embarrassing...
Don't look at my ugly tonsils...
Wait...
How do you know...
If you need your tonsils removed?
How would you know?
Is it a hurt thing?
You ask a doctor...
Do they hurt?
Swelling...
You have tonsillitis...
What if I get them out...
And I ask for them...
And I return them to me...
On a little plate...
And then we dissect them...
On string...
Keep them in a jar...
Whoa...
Sashibis?
Ew...
Then we eat it...
What is this?
The placenta?
Yeah...
The Spongebob movie scene...
What...
What scene are you talking about?
You could stream them being removed?
Okay...
I'll be like...
Okay doc...
Explain what you're doing...
Oh my gosh...
Would they...
Would they make me have that anesthesia?
Would I be talking silliness?
Illiness...
Yes?
What if...
What if I...
What if I get conked out...
And then...
My doctor starts talking...
Uh...
Smack about me...
And I'll...
What if he's like...
This stupid ghost...
I'll just tell him I'm a TikTok streamer...
I'm a TikTok influencer...
I could sue...
I could...
Yeah...
Everybody is watching...
That would be quite a feat, huh?
That would be the VTuber event of the year, maybe...
Me toes...
Throat surgery...
Yep...
It's peak...
It would be educational, I feel...
Probably...
Tonsil graduation...
I don't think I'll have to get my tonsils out...
But...
I hope I also don't need like a surgery...
Obviously...
We will see after...
After...
A...
Three month period...
Of me healing...
And what I'm gonna try and do...
Is also do like a pretty consistent...
I know I said that I would have no schedule...
But I'm gonna try and do like a...
Maybe like a Monday...
Thursday...
Sunday...
Kind of schedule...
So that you guys can...
Feel like there's a little bit of consistency, you know?
I don't know...
So...
Three times oblivion...
What if the doc played a karaoke stream?
Oh my gosh...
What if he...
Timed the stream to the songs?
Would Minto and...
Anesthesia be really more freaky than a normal Minto?
So I'm afraid of what I would ever say...
I've seen some...
I've...
I love watching those kinds of videos...
Of people on anesthesia...
Actually...
For those who know...
The artist Duskal...
She's my wife...
And she...
Had a tooth thing...
And she went on anesthesia...
And...
Um...
She...
I...
She sent me a video...
Of...
When she was...
She was being filmed...
And...
She...
Was asking for me...
So many wives...
Around here...
Yeah...
Like...
That person filming was just like...
Who do you wanna see?
And she was like...
I wanna see mint...
Even...
On...
Drugged up...
She was thinking about me...
So I want all of you guys...
To be the same...
But if I think...
If I were...
I don't know...
If I'm on anesthesia...
I'd be like...
Chat...
Is this real?
I'd be...
Oh my gosh...
I would probably ask for us a lot...
I think...
Oh my gosh...
That would be so embarrassing...
I don't want you guys to hear my real thoughts about him...
I don't guys...
My real thoughts about Metal Gear...
That would be...
The most embarrassing thing ever...
I will never...
I will never go on anesthesia...
And talk about...
My real thoughts on Metal Gear...
And I will never...
Get drunk and talk about my...
You don't know!
You guys...
You guys don't even...
You guys don't...
I've only scratched the surface...
You guys actually don't know so much...
I've never told you...
I've never told you... I do keep secrets sometimes... I do... I do keep my own secrets... enlighten us... Maybe one day... If I ever do a drunk stream... The truth will come out...
Non-filtered Metal Gear thoughts... What
kind of secrets?
Without being specific... A secret makes a woman... Woman... Gosh, I want to watch Conan... Detective Conan... I haven't watched in so long... She actually loves Naomi...
Drunk off collab straight with my wives...
That would involve everybody getting together... Might be kind of hard... I would like to do another off collab stream... Sometime though... It would be fun... You know, just also... Like... Singing French... And stuff... But I'll be seeing Koyo soon... I'll be seeing Coyote...
So definitely... Watch her graduation... 3D... She announced who else was in it... Oh my gosh... I can already feel my throat... Feel like... Sounding better... Because of that cough drop... I told you... It works so well... Um, hold on... She announced who it was... Let me go see... Uh,
she's sad... Uh, Dire Wolf... And Hululu... Oh my gosh...
Wonderful... We get to meet Hululu... That's like... So surreal though, no?
Like... I have... I have like... Kemono Friends mug... You know?
And I have... A boss... Plushie... Like... I really love... Kemono Friends... I can't believe... It's so... So surreal... And like... Hululu... Remember... Do you guys remember how... Hululu was the penguin that... Yeah, Grape Kunz Waifu...
Yeah, yeah... The Hululu was the penguin that... Um... That... Grape Kunz... The penguin fell in love with... Like the little standee... Yeah... How many years ago was that now?
Rip Grape Kunz... Yeah... Yeah... 87 years ago...
So yeah... I'm like...
Really honored... That... That Koyo asked me... Um... Like so so honored... Cause you know... Um... I think I've mentioned it before... But you know... I've... I've... Been friends with her... Um... We just never really... We just never really... Made it... Public... Or anything... You know... We never... Like we collabed that one time... Uh... Like a month ago or so... And... Um...
That we'll be collabing this week...
But... But... It's... It just goes to show... How... Much... You know... I guess... Is going on behind the scenes... You know... That you... Some... You would never know... What people know each other... Maybe... But... Um... I love Koyo... She's so cute... So talented... I'm a big fan of her... Actually... I... I... More than friends... I was a fan of her first... I was a fan of her first...
So... Um... Yeah... I'm really really happy... Hehehe...
So...
Mmm...
And of course... When the... When the graduation... Live... The farewell party... Happens... I will of course link it... So... Um... I'll try to link it... Uh... Uh... Uh... Uh... On Twitter... And on YouTube... So... Yeah... Yeah... Yeah... Yeah...
It just... Ghosts to show... Hehehehehe... Anyway... Okay... I know I said I was gonna call it... But I think... That's where I'll call it... Now... I think... Yeah... I'll go get some rest... I suck so much that... My voice was fine... And then the weekend happened... And... I... I really... I really didn't even... I didn't do anything...
My voice got so bad... I'm not gonna lie... I've been like... Legitimately... Depressed about it... Hehehe... And I think... Uh... For the next couple of months... I'll be pretty depressed about not being on the stream so much... So...
Sorry... I've been trying not to cry... This whole stream... Um... So... Uh... Yeah... I'll uh... I'll do my best to get better... And then we'll get back to normal... And then things will be... But... Also... Also... Things... Fun things are still going to happen... So... Um...
But also... If you hear me singing... Please remember... That... My voice does not be good... Hehehe... So... Don't be too... Judgy... Try not to judge too hard... If I don't sound so great... If I'm singing in things... I... Just don't want to say no to opportunities... Because... Opportunities are important... Hehehe... Hehehe... Okay... Okay... I'm gonna go... I'm gonna go...
Atomito... Atomito... Atomito... Thank you guys... And... Um... Um... Uh... Tomorrow I'm gonna play... Oblivion... I think... And
then I think... Wednesday... I'll have a collab... But it's like a... It's JST time... So it'll be early morning for me... Not sure if I'll stream it yet... I think we're still deciding on what the game... We wanna play... Me and Coyote... Actually... I think I will stream it... So that you guys can... Uh... Gonna miss you... I'll still be around...
Uh... I think I will stream it... So that you guys can... Intr... Be introduced to Coyote... If you don't know her... And if I don't do Oblivion tomorrow... If I'm just like... Ah... My voice is too bad... I'm sorry... I will make a post too... On Twitter... About everything that I said here...
Is Coyote... Coyote's... Chat okay with English... Yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah... Yeah yeah yeah...
Oh she's... She's fluent... In... Japanese and English... So it will be an English collab... No worries...
Yeah I think that's all I wanna say... I think that's all I wanted to say... So... Will the Twitter post include the narrator... But... That guy... If anybody has any funnier clips of the narrator...
Maybe not used by me... Maybe used by another VTuber... If any other VTubers have used the narrator voice... In the past... You should... Share them with... People that have not heard... The original narrator before... And that's all I'll say about that... Okay... Otumito... Thank you guys... Thank you thank you... Bye bye... Thank you... Bye bye... Bye bye... Bye bye...
Bye bye... Bye bye... Bye bye... Bye bye... Bye bye... Bye bye... Bye bye... Bye bye... Bye bye... Bye bye... Bye bye... Bye bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye... Bye